if you want to stop being poor stop
being a what up guys welcome to
the just pearly things YouTube channel
and welcome to my reaction series today
I'm gonna be reacting to Ben Shapiro
debunking these feminists debunk them
but guys before I start don't you forget
you want to be the ultimate the ultimate
Alpha you want women to come up to you
left and right and say you're so amazing
and awesome get yourself a women
shouldn't vote t-shirt today at the
audacity Network dot store that the
women won't stop approaching you you
won't even know what to do let's get to
Ben and his amazing debunking video only
supported the feminist movement and
supported the left are feeling
disenfranchised given the current
climate sexual brutality and oppression
brought to light in Hollywood recently
uh no I think they're just gonna blame
the same people they always blame
because we're all in our own little
bubbles should they feel this in
franchise 100 then
just Pander as in a society that treats
sex as transactional in a society that
basically reduces to any sort uh just a
physical transaction that is based
solely on consent it makes it very
difficult to explain why it is that the
casting couch in Hollywood is a bad
person right there's actually like okay
he didn't completely we're gonna wait he
says that it's bad because power
imbalances but the sort of libertarian
culture of the left suggests that power
imbalance doesn't have anything to do
with it if I feel like trading my body
for a part in a movie well that's my
business and if you say differently then
you're shaming right so that's it
well you can't really have it both ways
either it's bad or it's not bad and if
we are going to fight sexual harassment
and sexual assault it seems to me that
we have to do a couple we have to
reinvest sex with value beyond your
physical transaction it's not just two
people who are getting each other's
rocks off it actually means something
beyond that there's a relationship
that's attached to it um and beyond that
I think that we need so we've got to
tell women to stop being yeah I
think we got to bring back sludge
shaming to re-inculcate in men
themselves not just they teach men not
to rape routine one of the things that's
happened is that traditional masculinity
the idea that is a man his job to
protect women this is one of our jobs as
human beings as men protect women the
feminist movement doesn't like that well
then you can't blame us for not
protecting women yeah yep yep you don't
want us to protect women like I want to
protect women I think men should protect
women I think one of the reasons God put
man on Earth is to protect women okay
well then it is income but the question
is do women deserve to be protected do
do women today deserve protection they
don't mean to protect women but if
you're telling me that I can't even open
a door for a woman because this is
somehow an offense to her honor and that
if I say that it's man's job this is
somehow reinforcing gender stereotypes
then don't come whining to me when bad
stuff happens first thing that I hate
today is this insane piece by some crazy
person named Jody Allard she's
apparently a feminist blogger first of
all all feminist blogger I don't mean to
generalize she actually has a piece
today called the title of it is I'm done
pretending men are safe
your sons you can't even love your sons
I'd be such a good boy Mom I'd be like
you're right kids right it is their
fault two sons they're strong and
compassionate kind of boys other parents
are glad to meet when their daughters
bring them they're good boys and the
ways good boys are but they are not safe
I'm starting to believe there's wow can
you imagine growing up with this kind of
mom no such thing she is talking about
her own children being potential rapists
because I have a general recommendation
if you believe that all women are crazy
everybody's terrible maybe it's just you
maybe it's just you if every
relationship you've ever had has gone
bad maybe it's not all the people you
know are terrible maybe you suck all
right I Gotta Give a caveat to the man
you know what I mean we're kind of crazy
you know like
all right hear me out hear me out women
today are attention addicted we're
basically the equivalent of attention
addicts from the time we're like 12
years old that's the equivalent of a man
being given unlimited sex from the time
he's 12. um I think we're gonna see a
lot of chicks go crazy because of that I
I don't think it was intentional um I
think part of its consumerism but I do
think we have a school system that lets
women live in delusion we have a college
system that kind of ruins women
um and then we have a job market that
caters to women everything just favors
women so it kind of makes us a bit crazy
um and so I mean yeah I mean yeah it's
still your life circumstances are your
own fault but I do think women kind of
have we have delusional standards
nowadays okay and I'm gonna go with that
on this one just my sons won't rape
unconscious women behind a dumpster what
all of these men share in common even my
sons is a Relentless question I didn't
realize the common female experience was
raped while unconscious I know a few
females it's not yeah that's never
listen I don't know any of them who've
been raped while unconscious many
dumpster at least none who have told me
about it and if they tell me about that
I would say can we find the person and
hunt them down like that would be my
first reaction let me tell the police uh
my first reaction would be is this
lying or not sorry
Ben I've just heard it too many times I
think I'm a little I'm a little
traumatized slightly yeah there is my
Trauma from a year and a half or so the
way that we can kill this person and get
away with it like that seems like the
the best possible like is that not
feminist enough I do not want to prove
my pain provide enough evidence to
convince anyone that my trauma is
merited if you accuse someone of rape
you might have to provide evidence of
actual rape there we go there we go
thank you
any crime totally insane totally insane
Child Protective Services needs to show
up thank God it sounds like her sons are
getting old enough that they get to
leave home leave now leave now okay I
will try to find a way to put you up in
your own apartment seriously so what you
actually wrote is you wrote the Gorsuch
like Antonin Scalia is a proponent of
originalism which means he believes a
judge should attempt to interpret the
words of the Constitution as they were
understood at the time they were written
when the Constitution was written women
couldn't own property in 1787 women
didn't have the right to vote it would
be 133 years before women won 1600 that
was the first female property owner get
your facts straight
in that fight a fight they fought for 72
years considering women had no rights
when they come sorry guys I have such a
potty mouth I gotta stop ladies ladies
institution was written and there was no
mention of women in the constitution
originalism is sexist so let me ask you
first to expand on that well that's
because women are too dumb yeah that's
what I would say you think she would
take that well
the Constitution that sexist or
originalism that sexist or both it seems
that when it comes to women's rights
um originalist perspective tends to side
on the air of always Looking Backward
backward and not looking at current day
because because they're trying to
because if you're looking if I wrote a
piece of legislation 10 years ago and I
said to you okay are you and I write a
piece of legislation today right and we
use the language of today we mean
something by that language in this
conversation somebody will read this 100
years from now and we will have met what
we're saying to each other we understand
what we're saying if somebody wants to
read what we're talking about today and
then it turns out that all the words
that we're using now mean the reverse
because things have changed did our
conversation mean the reverse of what it
meant or does it mean what we're talking
about right now words have meaning at
the time they are said and to try and
read new meanings into old that's how
you can tell if someone's being
disingenuous because they'll say that
people couldn't have meant what they
said because they were oppressed women
were just so oppressed by their husbands
we can't trust their words words just
because quote unquote times have changed
you can end up with some really busy is
our result I mean and and the problem
here is that you know you like you may
not like what Neil Gorsuch is trying to
do but at least it's a rule of
interpretation in in the Constitutional
structure what we've had is the Supreme
Court very often reversing itself on the
exact same language by using the sort of
rules that you want so for example in
Plessy versus Ferguson you had the
Supreme Court say that the 14th
Amendment did not uh did not apply to
black people insofar as segregation was
okay and then 50 years after that they
say no it turns out the 14th Amendment
actually meant that segregation is not
okay anymore that's silly I mean it
either meant one or it meant the other
it didn't mean two different things at
the same time one of those decisions is
wrong and one of those decisions is
right that's true for every judicial
such a bad Shapiro thing I know tradcons
are really split on him but I love that
I'm like I'm like an OG Ben Shapiro
supporter the idea that we can just look
to our hearts to determine what a text
meant 200 years ago is is silly when we
can find out what they meant 200 years
ago by reading what they're talking
about now how about the idea that if
you're a woman that you're at some sort
of inherent disadvantage here in the
United States and that funny uh
conservatives really can just make like
millions of dollars basic facts women
are not oppressed you're living in the
freeze best place on Earth in history
for women at any time
all right how about the wage Gap this
idea that women are somehow victims in
the United States horrible
discrimination it's glass ceiling I'm
super oppressed please send me money
seriously
um my uh my my Super Chat super chat
with them at all times did only Hillary
Clinton's face can break
the fact is that in 147 out of 150 the
biggest cities in the United States
women make eight percent more than men
if they are single and unmarried and
have the same degree they earn more than
that
[Applause]
my mom and she adopted three kids three
not one on two but three do you really
think the Liberals like the left is
really adopting kids like that it's
always Christian conservatives like at
that church I was telling you about
earlier my neighbors adopted two kids
it's all the time it was super common in
that charity okay I do care about the
mother being poor I do care about Foster
well the mother wouldn't be poor if she
wasn't such a no I'm serious like
all these single moms it's just because
they make kids with like drug dealers
and like reproductive like choices so if
you want to stop being poor stop being a
what do we not is this not going
to catch on is this too far is that not
funny are we not he's laughing a little
bit you think I can put it on a t-shirt
what give me your he's like I'm staying
out of this one well Planned Parenthood
doesn't prevent them for hundreds of
thousands before 300 000 abortions
leading abortions
that they perform 300 000 abortions a
year from Planned Parenthood they don't
dispute that no one just Beats
you want to stop being poor stop being
[Applause]
stop being only fans but most of them
are still poor birth control is
extraordinarily
birth control it goes back to if you
can't afford if you can't afford birth
control if you want to stop being poor
stop being a
yes and it's true that most forms of
birth control are also extraordinarily
cheap most birth control is very cheap
and I'm not against Hood as you may have
noticed if you want to go to Planned
Parenthood and get a contraceptive I do
care when you start killing babies no I
think I'd ban it I think I I kind of
switched my opinion but yeah I'm I'm
thinking ban that yeah women really gave
up on Marriage a lot too soon okay
marriage was the best thing ever for
women it is an amazing it's an amazing
thing for men too because it civilizes
them and cultures them and teaches them
to be protective of their family and
take care of people think Beyond
themselves and think beyond their gender
women gave up in marriage a way to teach
men to do those things and also women
gave up the idea that a commitment was
going to come along with this intimacy
and let's be real about this I mean
every scientific study ever done has
shown that women actually do have better
sex in the context of committed
relationships all the crap that you see
in Cosmo magazine about sleeping with
100 guys and being sexually happy is
just garbage it is just sheer
unadulterated garbage
no they seem like so happy
[Applause]
no long answer to a short question but
reinculcation of traditional roles of
male and female the same feminist
respect that we ought to have for women
at all steps of the process is the
answer come on the channel come on Pearl
show I'm an OG fan you saved me I I was
saved by Ben Shapiro from I mean my dad
but like from liberalism so thank you um
all right guys let me know what you
think let me know if there's something
else you want me to react to like the
video on your way out subscribe to the
channel I'll talk to you next time